vous savez pas à quel point ça m'a
marqué moi le petit gars de penny au
portugal
j'ai représenté le québec officiellement
à part
[Musique]
l'ex ministre des finances carlos leitao
qui est fait ses adieux à l'assemblée
nationale la semaine dernière nous
l'avons souvent reçu comme économiste
prévisionnistes ministre des finances
carlos leitao tire donc sa référence sa
révérence il ne sera pas candidat à la
prochaine élection du mois d'octobre et
il est notre invité bonsoir carlos slim
soir beaucoup d'émotion beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion de de quitter de
tirer votre révérence qu'est ce qui ne
sert représente pour vous cette étape de
vie écoutez j'ai passé huit ans en
politique
ça c'est le petit clip in de l'assemblée
nationale était fier seulement 125 comme
ça au québec je suis un de ses 125 là et
pour moi c'est un très grand honneur de
pouvoir représenter les citoyens de ma
circonscription à québec et de essayé du
mieux que je pouvais de contribuer à
l'épanouissement du québec donc est ce
que les quatre dernières années cela dit
on était difficile vous avez été
ministre des finances pendant 4 à et
critique en matière de finances dans les
quatre dernières années est ce que si
ces difficultés-là d'être dans
l'opposition qui vous fait dire bon j'ai
assez donné euh non non honnêtement
quand je me suis lancé dans cette grande
aventure on avait fait un conseil de
famille moi et ma femme on s'était dit
écoute je vais faire ça pendant huit ans
deux mandats c'est tout passé le régler
à se dérégler oui on sait on s'était dit
deux mandats que ce soit au gouvernement
ou dans l'opposition quoi que ce soit
ses deux mandats pas plus mais pas moins
non plus donc deux mandats et puis on
passe à une autre étape après et c'est
ce que j'ai fait quand on vous a reçu il
ya huit ans vous nous aviez dit c'était
à l'époque de la charte des valeurs le
parti québécois se présente en 2014 avec
la charte des valeurs et vous m'aviez
dit que c'était la raison fondamentale
pourquoi vous vous lanciez en politique
est-ce que pas des éléments avec la loi
96 la loi 21 qui peuvent ressembler à
cet état d'esprit de 2014 qui pourrait
vous amener à continuer beaucoup
beaucoup d'éléments et je voudrais même
que aujourd'hui 2026 et même plus
complexe est à mon avis plus préoccupant
que en 2014 maintenant il ya plusieurs
façons de pouvoir
intervenir dans le débat public je suis
arrivé à la conclusion aussi non
seulement il y avait le dire familial
mais aussi je pense que je pourrais être
plus utile à la société québécoise dans
ce débat justement en étant à
l'extérieur d'assemblée nationale que en
étant dans un cadre très très formel à
l'intérieur d'asablah ce parce que là
vous partez de l'assemblée nationale
vous avait 66 ans si je me trompe pas
mais vous n'accrochez pas vos patins
pour autant vous voulez faire quoi je
suis encore beaucoup trop jeune pour
accrocher ses patins donc j'ai pas de
projets spécifiques honnêtement j'ai pas
de projets spécifiques mais je vais
rester engagés je vais rester non
seulement c'est un jeu politique
identitaire mais aussi rester engagés en
termes de finances en quelque chose qui
me qui meuble qui me fascine et que je
trouve extrêmement intéressant et utile
c'est tout au tout la finance verte va
falloir procéder à un changement
écologique transition énergétique
et la finance un énorme rôle à jouer
là-dedans il nous faut des milliards et
milliards $ et donc comment les actions
sur financières peuvent participer à cet
effort là c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup de quoi il est vous
le plus fier à
beaucoup je voudrais 2 de l'ensemble de
l'oeuvre mais il ya une chose à part
celle que vous avez le petit segment que
vous avez passé une chose qui m'a qui
m'a vraiment je suis hyper hyper fier
c'est le jour de mon dernier budget mars
2018 où bon vous savez en budget sur
très formel une liste finances dit
j'annonce fais ci fais ça puis abandonné
j'ai arrêté de discours j'ai regardé en
haut et on ma mère était assise et j'ai
remercié ma mère et puis l'a
spontanément tous les députés de tous
les partis d'opposition vont tout le
monde s'est levé et tout le monde
applaudit ma mère là j'ai encore je suis
d'accord l'émotion quand j'ai dit ça
mais pour moi ça c'était vraiment le
moment le plus le plus fort de ma vie
politique est encore de ce monde mais
encore oui oui encore très très très
bien et encore très bien et je lui ai
dit que les pies jamais dit ça ya des
bagarres c'est maintenant pour moi
c'était vraiment pas ce que nous sommes
et c'est important parce que je suis un
immigré
et de remercier ma mère parce que c'est
elle qui est allée mon père ce sont eux
qui ont tout sacrifié moi je suis arrivé
ici j'avais 18 ans écoute et ceci
c'était facile pour moi et je pense que
je suis quand même intégré assez
facilement mais pour mes parents c'était
les grands sacrifices ils ont tout
laissé derrière ils ont mon père avait
une bonne vie professionnelle ils ont
tout laissé derrière pour que nous nous
sommes cinq pour connaissent un coup
nous les cinq puissions avoir un
meilleur avenir donc je trouvais ça est
extrêmement important de remercier ma
mère pour son sac qu'est ce que ça
représente d'être ministre des finances
pour un immigrant au québec c'est
important pour vous c'était très
important et puis en plus pour un
économiste
justifie dans ce monde a maintenant tu
es de l'autre côté tu peux faire non
mais c'était
c'était énorme parce que
quand on est en politique je pense que
nous sommes un modèle qu'on ne veuille
qu'on ne veuille pas nous sommes un
modèle pour pour repris hier pour la
pollution dans notre cas dans la
communauté portugaise mais les autres
aussi je pense que c'est important
d'avoir des modèles c'est d'autant
qu'avec les plus jeunes plus que se voir
présenter regarde si lui l'a fait ça
donc moi aussi je peux aspirer à faire
ça donc c'est important c'est important
d'avoir des modèles et j'espère tout
simplement que j'ai été capable de du
mieux que je pouvais d'être ce modèle
qu'est ce qu'est ce que ça vous fait
quand on dit que vous avez été un
ministre de rigueur et d'austérité
à regarder les je pense qu'un jour et
déjà c'est déjà fermé mais je pense
notamment aux travaux de luc godbout de
matthieu chéreau qui a déjà écrit une
petite pièce en disant que peut-être
l'austérité faudrait repenser aux termes
quand on allie un alice ac va être
réduite et toujours pour moi je pensais
vraiment la rigueur mais quoi que ce
soit le terme qu'il utilise je pense qu
on a fait ce qu'on pensait qu'ils
étaient la chose à faire dans le but
ultime de replacer le québec les
finances publiques du québec dans un
état soutenable à long terme c'était ça
notre objectif je pense qu'on a réussi
l'histoire après le confirmera ou pas ma
dernière question c'est pour
l'économiste oui vraiment je parle à
l'économie si nos politiciens parce que
vous l'êtes encore respectable quand
même une élection qui s'en vient s
conservant récession honnêtement je ne
sais pas mais ce que je sais c'est que
nous allons dans une nous sommes déjà
dans une situation où l'inflation est
élevée elle va demeurer très élevé et
les taux d'intérêt augmentent eux même
peut-être plus vite que ce qu'on pense
les situations de ralentissement
économique très fort et inflation très
élevé on n'a pas vu ça depuis très très
longtemps et les citoyens ne savent pas
non plus comment s'ajuster a donc le
sentiment d'en sécurité en sécurité
économique en sécurité financière ce
sentiment est très fort ça fait
peut-être 30 40 ans qu'on n'avait pas
vécu ce sentiment là et ça peut donner à
toutes sortes de réactions
bon nous parle mais des réactions
politiques publiques faut faire
attention bon été merci beaucoup une
suite des choses on va rappeler
l'économiste certainement merci car
c'est ça me fait grand plaisir merci
beaucoup pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit